voice of baseball and certainly on MLB
Network Bob Costas back here on the show
how are you Bob hi rich how you doing
well I'm just gonna generally give you
the floor what do you think about what
baseball did and what's uh and and the
penalties and everything surrounding all
of this Bob well this is the defining
moment of Rob Manfred's commissioner
ship so far
he drew a very clear line in the sand
this wasn't just about punishment for
the Astros and likely for the Red Sox
and Alex Cole coming up shortly this was
designed not just to mete out a
punishment but to send an unmistakable
message they have to be concerned not
just with existing technology but
probably by the time this segment is
over new technology will emerge
certainly in the upcoming years
technology that can be used and missed
within baseball and other sports so
baseball and all sports have to get
ahead of it maybe baseball more so than
any other because you're not using
headsets the way they do and football on
all the rest is still dependent upon
hand signals which can be stolen and
decoded and as we all know stealing
signs using your whips and powers of
observation not only is allowable its
applauded it shows on high baseball IQ
that's gamesmanship but using technology
within the game technology as part of
the analytics and the new modern
approach to baseball in terms of
preparation that's fine you can use all
the technology you want until they throw
the first pitch but other than looking
at the replay monitor in the case of a
challenge in which case now MLB has
security people there to make sure you
can't use it for any other purpose other
than that I think the next step is that
there is no technology allowable no
technology of any kind allowable once
the first pitch has been thrown
so that will inoculate baseball at least
in theory against whatever new
techniques are coming
look we're not
define it and and reanalyze it each time
something new comes along anything other
than powers of observation and the naked
eye once the first pitch is thrown is
not allowable and if you think the risk
or the reward rather is worth the risk
look at the penalties that just were
handed down to the Astros to Lou now and
to Hinch and for that matter to Crane
and take a look at what's coming for
Korra in the Red Sox bob cost is here on
the Rich Eisen show and that's that my
first blush reaction on the technology
front as you as you just went there
first
when I heard this yesterday was maybe
replay is in jeopardy but you're
basically saying having a babysitter
next to whoever is part of the replay
system in each major league baseball
team to let a manager know in the
clubhouse to challenge or not that would
handle it along with the banning on any
technology once a first pitch is thrown
do you think that that would actually
bottle it up Bob
yeah would and yeah well they can also
put the replay system on at least if
we're talking about live shots they
could put that on a short delay only a
few seconds is enough to ensure that you
can't relay the information to the
hitter in time now this is not gonna
stop anybody from taking the tape of the
game and you're also going to be banned
by the way from having your own cameras
in center field or wherever but you
could take the tape of the game and
analyze it that's going to be done
anyway
players as you know look at their every
at-bat to analyze what might have
happened the last time I faced this
picture or how they can get out of a
slump but what you're not going to be
allowed to do is you strike out looking
in the second inning and before you come
up again in the fourth or fifth you've
gone down the tunnel and you've watched
every pitch of this at-bat now that may
be helpful in a legitimate way to the
hitter but the secondary aspect of that
is that that could be misused to cheat
so they're gonna have to ban they're
gonna have to ban that you've also got
this is peripheral but you've also got
pace of play issues in baseball and this
is one of the many
that compounds that problem because not
only our team's attempting to to steal
information but other teams are so
paranoid about it that they're going
through more more signals NASA it takes
you know requires growing off and
landing you know you got catchers with
information on their wristbands that
that look like their quarterbacks you
know but but the difference is in
football you got time between plays
that's already built in in baseball
these guys check-in it between pitches
and some of this is interminable and
part of it not all of it part of it is
because they're so concerned about
espionage right and and and the
wristbands are different for each
pitcher as is the signal sequence for
each pitcher so if you have two or three
pitching changes in the span of an
inning or an inning and a half and then
the catcher gets a different wristband
and the pitcher has it different I guess
the Nationals had a different signal
sequence that was placed under the Bills
of the caps of all the pitchers because
they knew the Astros were were coming to
town I mean this is the sort of
cat-and-mouse play that that's been
going on the last couple of years Bob
Costas here and a whole lot of a lot of
paranoia sure in the game right
incidental although obviously the focus
is the Astros for now and then soon
enough the Red Sox and they aren't just
the team's accused but the teams that
have won two of the last three World
Series and it could have been all three
because the answer is barely lost this
past October so it's very high-profile
and involved in Chandpur a-- who are
universally regarded as two of the best
managers in the game and very young and
they're appealing and their media
friendly and they're popular so for all
those reasons this is a very high
profile but the report issued yesterday
also indicated that the commissioner in
the course of this investigation became
aware that at least eight other teams
might very well have had schemes of
their own those teams just weren't as
successful Bob Costas here on the Rich
Eisen show and as you point out I mean
we've had AJ Hinch here on the show many
times also after the hurricane
displaced the astros and and obviously
the Texans a couple of summers ago and
and that was he it's just a bummer you
know it's like saying ain't so AJ and
then you see that that in the report
there to which you refer Manfred said
that
Hinch let it be known he didn't like
this to the point where he destroyed a
couple of monitors then why why did he
not say let's let's hold off on the Code
Red I mean he's the manager of the team
how do you that
what is that mentality what's that
psychology at work you're Bob rat to me
is so mystifying he wasn't a manager
trying to find his footing
he was extremely well accepted look in
2017 when when the initial accusations
are focused on they hadn't yet won a
World Series but they were on their way
to that he had great respect in the
clubhouse at least one player is quoted
in the report as saying if AJ had told
us to stop we would have stopped so AJ
makes it clear and I believe him but he
didn't initiate it and he didn't approve
of it in fact as you said he he damaged
two of the monitors they were using
which indicates he indicates disapproval
but he never flatly said and I would
think that this is the greatest regret
of his life he never flatly said hey
guys look this is outside regular
gamesmanship this isn't allowed we're
good enough without this and that's
really the shame of it they were good
enough without this it isn't like they
needed this to achieve what they
achieved Lou now is legitimately one of
the brightest minds in the modern
history of the sport
Hinch is an extraordinarily good manager
look at the quality of their players
they didn't need to do this it's a
self-inflicted wound that if AJ had
simply said we're not gonna do it and
anybody who tries to do it is going to
have to hear from me and the whole damn
thing would have stopped let's talk a
little bit about the fallout here Bob
Bob Costas here on the Rich Eisen show
of
your fans in this town are pissed I'm
gonna lie they're very very upset they
lost the 2017 World Series albeit Game
seven was here in Los Angeles where one
imagines I guess you could bring a trash
can but oh the Dodgers tweeted out a
response and as I'm sure they issued it
in other conventional manners I want to
read it all clubs have been asked by
Major League Baseball not to comment on
today's punishment of the Houston Astros
as it's inappropriate to comment on
discipline imposed on another club the
Dodgers have also been asked not to
comment on any wrongdoing
we wrongdoing during the 2017 World
Series and we'll have no further comment
at this time
to me that's akin to raising a banner in
centerfield with a big Dodger blue
asterisk Bob I'm wondering what you
think well pretty clear how many of the
Dodgers and many of their fans are going
to interpret this and for that matter
other teams that along the way lost to
the Astros in closed series like the
Yankees it's legitimate for Joe Girardi
to wonder whether a close loss to the
Astros in which is if I recall correctly
they lost every one of the games at
Minute Maid Park in a seven-game series
whether that close defeat winds up
costing him his job there's a lot of
fallout from this but there's no way
that these results are going to be
voided
they didn't void the result of the 1919
World Series the record book still says
the Cincinnati Reds are the world
champions
they didn't void Barry Bonds
single-season or career home run records
although any person with half a brain
knows that as great as Bonds was on his
natural merits those achievements are
not fully authentic and neither are the
statistics of many other players from
the so called steroid era they're not
going to take Gaylord Perry out of the
Hall of Fame although everybody knows he
threw a spit ball what happens here is
that history and fans and people like us
will make our own judgments and how much
weight we give to it will vary from
person to person but there's no question
that it's a taint on the Astros as a
team
and sadly it's a taint on the individual
people who have been sanctioned and
these are people of high achievement and
it's coming next for Alex Cora because
Cora was as you know the top lieutenant
the bench coach in Houston for Hinch in
2017 and the Red Sox are involved in
another allegation not the same but
similar using technology in a way that
is prohibited and Manfred's Office had
issued a warning about this previously
so long ago we didn't know will be good
going forward no the warning was already
in place so we know that Cora and the
roads are just going to get whacked to a
significant extent it's a shame and it's
going to be a taint on all those people
and they are people of high achievement
and high quality who didn't need it and
also need to do it exactly in the end
players as well involved in this I have
pounded this table on my set about a
Jose Altuve may be already being
hall-of-famer based on what he's been
able to achieve and you know for as long
as we've known each other I'm a Yankee
fan and watching Altuve turn on an
off-speed pitch from a 100 mile an hour
fastball pitcher like Aroldis Chapman
this ALCS this one in light of
everything that's come out the
interpretation of Chapman's smile as
Altuve runs the bases is like this guy
knew it was coming and I don't know what
to think so I lay it at the feet of you
you be my conscience here Bob I mean
what should I think about Altuve and the
rest of these Astros now here's the
thing when there's paranoia and when
people have not just paranoid concerns
but legitimate concerns at the feet of
that isn't it just possible that a great
hitter guests and guests right sure that
arm that you Darvish was tipping his
pitches in game
seven of the World Series in 2017 and as
it allows the outing for the Dodgers all
those things are certainly possible in
fact even likely if that's been going on
forever in baseball a guy guesses right
or they steal signs are picked something
up with legitimate powers of observation
that's part of the game but if we also
know that cheating through prohibited
technology was part of the game the last
years then anybody is free to speculate
well in this situation that's why this
happened and when you're on the losing
side either as player or fan they said
the tendency to attributed to that is
all the greater all right so last word
for you Bob I know you you have some
thoughts that maybe others have not kind
of kicked the rock and on this scandal
and uncovered what may be next what what
do you what are you thinking about the
next steps and the ripple effect is this
large stone hits the major league pond
here well the Astros fired AJ Hinch and
Jef Luna now the Red Sox have a new
general managers so the previous regime
at least in that position not at issue
it doesn't follow that let's assume
Korah and this is widely assumed this
isn't just me it's widely assumed that
he's going to get a year maybe more but
at least let's say a year
the Astros fired Hinch
the Red Sox don't have to fire Korra
they could do the same thing the Saints
did with Sean Payton hey here's a really
good coach he suspended for a year we'll
tread water we want them back so let's
say that happens with the Red Sox you
can take somebody from the present staff
well maybe this is a situation where you
say if he gets a year or even more so if
he gets two maybe this is where you say
this is a perfect situation for Buck
Showalter here's a guy in his mid-60s
one more go-around we got a team that's
that's a contender obviously are capable
of contending let's plug him in there as
soon as the decision comes down with the
Red Sox there's going to be there's
going to be some speculation and that
risk
that the biggest winner in the offseason
here is the Yankees not only do they get
Gerrit Cole which would be a huge plus
no matter what but obviously they took
him from the Astros a team that they
were always likely to meet at some point
along the way in the postseason if they
were ever gonna get to the World Series
so subtract cold from the Astros and
Adam City Yankees now the Astros lose
their terrific manager and their genius
general manager and the Red Sox who
already had issues Mookie Betts contract
coming up is they trade David price
coming off a terrible season last year
now it's pretty certain that they're
gonna be without Alex Cora for a while
who benefits the most from this at least
competitively I would say it's the
Yankees who do and then the next
question is this a lot of people were
asking since the players initiated this
by all accounts and by what's in the
report the players initiated this in
Houston why were no players sanctioned
Manfred said because in effect the
adults in the room are the managers the
coaches the front office we hold them
responsible for the culture Plus since
almost every player those who benefited
and those who simply know about it
almost every player in the clubhouse
know about it how do you begin to sort
all that out if you begin to pull on
that thread the whole tournament
unravels we're not going to sanction any
players which apparently includes Carlos
Beltran who was in his last year as a
player in 2017 and at a very high
baseball IQ and was definitely part of
the system for the Astros in 2017 now
the manager the Mets okay remember how
during the steroid era the position for
the longest time of the Players
Association was they were gonna resist
any kind of testing any kind of
meaningful punishments and that
eventually the players as a group said
hold on we have an interest in this the
players who are playing clean or
victimized by this or some of them feel
pressured into using peds just to keep
up so this
situation isn't just a question of
protecting the guilty you're victimizing
the innocent the same thing is true
maybe in a less obvious way but it's
true when you're talking about this kind
of cheating there are victims in this
victims on the other side players who
are statistics are standing within the
game or adversely affected so now with
an upcoming negotiation about to take
place between management and the Players
Association I think a very good case
could be made that we need to put
specific penalties in place for players
who take part in illegal cheating not
gamesmanship but real cheating we have
to put it in place and the way we're
pitching this to Tony Clarke and the
Players Association is is to say if we
but most of your players don't cheat and
don't want others to cheat against them
then this is in our mutual interest to
hammer out a fair and reasonable system
that says look here are the penalties
beforehand the commissioners not making
it up on the fly this will happen to you
and if all that is in place you ought to
have enough of a deterrent to everybody
players coaches managers front office
people everybody in the game to
eliminate or substantially reduce this
Bob you are the man sir I you're the
first person I thought of got to get on
the show to talk about all this and I
really appreciate the time let's chat
down the road very soon do you have any
feel left considering how long I just
went on do you know what Bob there's
it's a three-hour extravaganza we I mean
I know that we're reshuffling the
rundown as we speak it was worth every
second how does that sound and it is an
extravaganza you every day take care of
Bob that's Bob Costas
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app